سلسله من الجدل شهدتها منظومه التعليم في
مصر ومحورها الدروس الخصوصيه التي تشكل
ظاهره توصف بالسلبيه وزاره التربيه
والتعليم بصدد التقدم بمشروع قانون مجلس
النواب خاص باصدار رخصه مزاوله مهنه
المعلم حسب المصادر بدون هذه الرخصه لن
يتمكن اي خريجه من المشاركه في التعليم
باي شكل من الاشكال سواء في مدرسه خاصه او
مركز تعليميه وسيتم معاقبه المخالفين
بتهمه امتحان صفات معلم هذا الاجراءات بعد
انتقادات واسعه لتصريحات وزير التربيه
والتعليم عن نيته ترخيص مراكز الدروس
الخصوصيه لهذا في جعلها بيئه امنه الدوله
حقها من ضرائب عائدات الدروس الخصوصيه
والتي تبلغ سبعه 47 مليار جنيه
الوزير دافع عن نفسه قائلا انها فكره
وليست قرار ليطالب بتجريمها واغلاقها 70%
منها
[موسيقى]
كل الدنيا بتستفاد دلوقتي من من سنتر
الشباب وبنات واطفال صغيرين بيتعلموا كثير
جدا القصه دي مشترك فيها اثنين المدرس
والتلميذ
المدرس مستغل
التلميذ عشان التلميذ بليد وما بيذاكرش
وبي حياته كلها بقت النت
والسوشيال ميديا والحاجات ديت لكن
طبيعي الطبيعي ان المدرسه تقوم بدورها
محتاجين ان احنا نزود اعداد المدارس
العيال الكثافه التلاميذ في الفصول نعمل
اجور ومرتبات مجزيه ومناسبه للمدرسين اللي
يقوموا بعمالهم
هو مقترح المشروع القانون
يستهدف حوالي 70% من
المعلمين العاملين في سيناء الدروس
الخصوصيه
هنتكلم عن 70% من الخريجين اللي عاملين في
مراكز الدروس الخصوصيه بدون رخصه مزاوله
مانع يعني هم مش معلمين يعني الخريج
لا لا احصاء رسمي وزاره التربيه والتعليم
منا 70% من العاملين في مراكز التروس
خصوصيه مش معلمين ولم يحصلوا على رخصه
مزاوله مهنه ال 30% الباقيين يعني نتكلم
عن دول اللي هم شغالين في المدارس
الحكوميه
مقترح مشروع القانون بيتكلم عن المعلم
اللي شغال في سنتر تعليمي واللي شغال في
مدرسه خاصه همم معظم المعلمين اللي شغالين
في مدارس خاصه في مصر
من التربيه والتعليم يعني المدرسه بتجيبهم
من همم الكليه
خلاص بيشتغل معها في المدرسه
الدوليه فقط
لو نجح فيها بياخد رخصه مزوره منها خلاص
ما نجحش فيها خلاص ولازم يكون منضم لنقابه
المعلمين والوزاره امام الشحها الموارد
والازمه الاقتصاديه قررت الاستعانه
بالمعلمين بالحصه او معلمين متطوعين مجانا
وده لا يمكن يعالج من الافضل
في النظام التعليمي قبل مناقشه الدروس
خصوصيه التي الطلاب هم بحاجه اليهم
ما هو ده السبب اللي خلى اولياء الامور
متحفزين جدا ضد ان احنا هنعمل شرعانا
للضروسيه في مصر لان ده كده الحكومه بترفع
يديها عن التعليم الحكومي في مصر طبعا
امام غضب المعلمين تم تجديد تم تجميد
المخترع يعني يمكن معلومه لحضرتك تم تجميد
مقترح تقنين الدروس الخصوصيه واعتقد ان
البديل هو رخصه من زاويه مهنه لان الوزاره
ما تعرفش مين واقف في السنتر بيشرحه ولي
الامر نفسه ما يعرفش مين واقف في سنتر
بيشرح هل هو معلم معترف به من الوزاره ولا
معلم وتطفل ولا بخيل على المهنه عشان كده
الوزاره قررت تعمل نقطه الوزاره
على الاقل اللي هم دخلاء على المهنه
يخرجوا من السنافر